Iron Man vs. Master Chief special
request from I heat voices 94 if you
have your own requests stick them in the
comments
Iron Man hands down the winner you
Rosalie your Master Chief AHA is part of
an army
Iron Man works all by himself Master
Chief has some guns Iron Man has like 90
different suits all specialized Master
Chief pulls triggers Iron Man makes the
technology that makes the weapons were 2
words the flood two words scroll
invasion scroll visions nothing compared
to the flood nobody could stop the flood
except for Master Chief no man in a
frickin suit over technology that he
would have to sit in a lab for nine
months to devote all the Master Chief
has to do is come over to Iron Man in an
off day BAM dead done you know well the
discussion Master Chief's a badass
Master Chief has never made a bad
product and there's been terrible Iron
Man comic books mastered the Halo novels
are awesome you know they're not you
can't even talk with a straight face
I can't even say it with a straight face
to summarize Iron Man has the advantage
in technology intelligence and the
number of battles he's been in Master
Chief has the advantage of the future
the flood fighting the Covenant and not
ever not being master chief your your
points don't even they're not even point
yes they what Tony Stark could not kill
a covenant this is just stupid this is
stupid
he couldn't handle the fun you get
overwhelmed you know here are the
reasons I like Superman more Cape
kryptonite Smallville that's what you
just did things genius these are trashy
these are attributes that would make him
win in the fight unflappable you put the
two of them in a cage match no weapons
Master Chief's gonna walk out there the
winner Ironman has multiple different
types of armor he'd wear his Hulk armor
the armor that he uses to fight the Hulk
hand-to-hand combat style and he would
crush Master Chief like he was nothing
okay no technology no dogs out of their
suits Master Chief would win so now it
no now it's just the Jimmy nobody now
again
chief because that's not his name that's
not a name nobody named chief nope
nobody names a kid Master Chief that was
his birth name it's on the first ticket
I will go get it because I have a copy
of collector's edition copy of his you
you you go get that you go get that and
I will wipe my butt with that all right
because it's not real
unlike Tony Stark a real man a man for
tomorrow he likes him because he wants
to sleep with him mmm that's not true
here's nothing Tony Stark drunk drunk
half the time still kills everybody so
your sign with Tony Stark because he's
an alcoholic okay and he'll I win I
don't you die when you don't have a
single message chief not an alcoholic
Tony Stark alcoholic ding Master Chief
you know the sad thing that you do the
editing for this so I know at the end of
this is gonna just pop up Oh Master
Chief wins like right right there it's
right there I knew you'd do it Jeff why
did you do
Oh
ah